carole ma chérie tu vas nous faire un
grand concours et chroniqueur et clément
je crois qu'il doit aller chercher des
scoops à l'aréna clément parce que
clément voilà il voulait en manque de ce
couple faut que j'achète
il va je vais prendre la place de
clément ont de grands concours des
chroniqueurs d'innovateur je vous jure
je laisse mon je laisse mon tel ici et
je laisserais mon oreillette voit la
jolie je laisse mon oreillette je laisse
mon tél je me mets là bas c'est parti
c'est avec tarbes
[Applaudissements]
comment
ça me fait quelque chose quand même un
plein avait 17 ans et emi sony septet
est formidable car le métier que même
moi j'ai l'impression de rejouer avec
toi là j'ai une pression sur la tête de
ma mère mais je me suis pas entraîné non
je suis pas sûr d'avoir le même débit
que d'habitude vous ne voudrez pas chers
téléspectateurs
est-ce que vous êtes prêts il est vu la
voix de caroline oui on est tout de
suite dedans ça arrive et c'est un truc
de fou
voici les règles de ce grand concours
des chroniqueurs deux manches une finale
classique dans la mer manche
vous jouez tous en même temps je vais
vous poser dix questions avec quelques
possibilités de réponses et vous devrez
répondre en choisissant votre réponse
sur le desk d'accord les quatre qui
marqueront le plus de points seront
qualifiées pour la deuxième manche
chaque bonne réponse vous rapporte 1
point en cas d'égalité d'égalité au bout
d partagera avec une question spéciale
est-ce que vous êtes prêts oui
cyril car des mois de tarbes en copie
mais personne ne copiera sur moi je dis
bien personne
on y va allez hop c'est parti première
manche les premières questions quelle
est la capitale de la turquie à istanbul
mais ankara 3 a laissé galatasaray jésus
c'est bon ça y est c'est bon alors à
istanbul b ankara 3 e c galatasaray des
salades tomates oignons tomates oignons
c'est parti j'ai déjà répondu comme au
sud ça y est vous avez tous répondu oui
c'est alors on y va
question numéro 2 on n'a pas l'habitude
pose que des questions
bref je vous les donne tout de suite
mais la bonne réponse et la réponse b en
quarts a alors fait des bonnes réponses
ou pas mais bien que mathieu chabot des
abers bâtiment c'est la bonne réponse
mais que manque est bon non non non
c'est bon ils ont tous bons pourquoi 40
[Rires]
bien les droits concours vous n'avez pas
répondu ainsi vite j'ai répondu au
dollar et toulouse où il a des rêves il
ya des règles d'appareils redescendu
aucune contestation possible au régime
revoyez volley messieurs en question
aient quitté mon rôle de chroniqueur
gémir munich et votre as alesis pas au
bonheur des dames est un livre 2 a ainsi
honoré de balzac b du staff flaubert
c'est jean michel maire d emile zola top
c'est parti
voilà j'ai répondu la référence je la
donne oui des merdes
yes pourtant sévère c'est juste moi il
n'y a que matthieu delormeau qui n'a pas
donné la bonne marche des bush a demandé
tu me lis je sais pas
[Rires]
je dis bravo origine c'est d'ailleurs en
régie c'est bon ils te disent que c'est
bon il arriva il me disait rien du tout
pourquoi mais pas l'oreillette et on
continue mais tes lauriers la normale n
auriez j'en ai connu avant l'été
comment appelle-t-on un triangle dont
tous les angles sont égaux s'est pas
fait mise au sel ces communistes des
rectangles top c'est parti
comment appelle-t-on à sion dont tous
les angles sont égaux achille à il
s'agit de la réponse à l'aigu latéral et
il n'y a que cyril hanouna qui est donné
on a beau temps maîtrise et il a résolu
un problème il avait des problèmes avec
la table donc à temps si je peux suivre
les résultats quelques jeunes et des
blancs pas son origine
soyez bons en régie chez vous merci et
bon avons rectifié géraldine maillet
elle n'a pas donné une bonne réponse à
la question connaissez de cette tâche
aux trois questions qui donnait les
trois bonnes réponses est à six points
cyril mais disent ils font n'importe
quoi faire aller aux origines je savais
qu'ils allaient comme un con mais trois
points tout le monde parce que je suis
vraiment très sympa est ce que j'avais
coupe à défaire à l'oral soins et le
soutien savez quoi maintenant voilà
alors al wihda les questions suivantes
napoléon bonaparte est né à au xviie
siècle b au xviiie siècle c'est au 19e
siècle
le même jour qu isabelle morini alors la
bonne réponse et la réponse b 18e siècle
en 1869
c'est aucune culture toshirô vasile
avoir placé la barre haut la main se
fait pas à la table on verra ça je fais
encore la table et chant il paraît qu
ils font les comptes en régime ne vous
inquiétez pas la question suivante
et donc ma question est la première m'a
dit si on est à 7 d'accord très bien
passé de ça va pas assez vite je peux
accélérer très bien qu'à toi tu es très
bien comment s'appelait les deux tribus
de la première saison de koh lanta à les
bords en contrôlant les lentes anaïs et
sa baie les temps morts contre les
ventes anas ses bourreaux contre les
machines cadets puis contre les marolles
doosan top c'est par le jeu c'est la
belgique n'a pas ça s'affiche pas la
réponse mais toujours me dit pas
satisfait aux régimes non ça s'affiche
banc et b alors non je vais vous dire
alors il a dit l'abbé je suis au près
souple et ses bas c'était la reprise et
la réponse là voilà merci voilà donc
castaldi avait amerri faut nous on a lu
regardé prennent ils prennent toutes les
notes en régie ne vous inquiétez pas
question de jouer en équipe à 90 n'avait
pas répondu
la dernière question sur servat passe
alors à la presse au quai d'où est
originaire la spécialité culinaire la
piperade pas de marseille 2-2 catalogne
tué match de rodez du pub a commencé non
aujourd'hui la cia réponse mais la
réponse des pays basque la piperade brad
magnifique la compa s'allie à une
dernière qui a une dernière question
vous y attend ça marche
tantôt sa revanche lequel de ces pays a
déjà remporté une coupe du monde de
football à la belgique b l'uruguay et le
mexique délation on a toujours la sienne
question attend piva fallait regarder
encore alerté la mais si vous regardez à
travers lui c'est la paix la bonne
réponse est débouté par la réponse b
l'uruguay il a gagné quand l'eau bout et
leur gouaille de gagner 1930 1931 et et
1900 1950 ma vo gilbert garde
carole donc qu'est ce qui se passe à
yakouren qualifie ya quand même à
l'aller 4 qualifiées pour la 2e manche
sont cyril hanouna à la triche à la
corée du nord
[Applaudissements]
de ce côté ça triche et s'assure une
fausse réponse est oui il avait t il dit
vous avez péché merci à l'écouté carole
comment ça se passe mais alors ça le
sont éliminés vous êtes éliminé vous
allez dans le public y est allé d'un
public mamadou berthé deuxième manche
oui elle est plutôt quatre cd thème
maintenant oui huitaine vont apparaître
sur l'écran
choisissez un terme comme je rêve un
premier jet de chaussure voilà le
meilleur de la première manche est ce
que c'est cyril hanouna le meilleur de
la première manche qui a su c'est lui
qui choisit le premier nommé je prends
le sport sport et après vous choisissez
un domaine les uns après les autres et
le meilleur jeu disons que là bas alors
sport 1 2 3 4 5
voilà j'en conviens temps une minute
pour répondre à un maximum de questions
vous êtes prêts oui j'ai peur en seriez
vous êtes prêt en chrono
shannon hockey qui a remporté le
championnat de ligue 1 de football la
saison dernière bonne réponse de quelle
couleur est le maillot du vainqueur du
classement général du tour de france a
lieu jaune quan réponses auxquelles
surface ce jour le tournoi de tennis de
wimbledon herbe bonnes réponses auront
lieu les jeux olympiques d'été de 2020
tokyo une réponse quelle est la
nationalité du footballeur nema oui
c'est bien pour une réponse quel est le
seul français à avoir été champion du
monde de formule 1 c'est alain prost
bonne réponse vrai ou faux cyril hanouna
et champion du monde de paddle
c'est faux bonne réponse à 5 cm très
confirmé sur le champion de judo teddy
riner qui mesure 2 m 2 m 0,4
quel tennisman à remporter le tournoi
simple homme roland garros de 2019 enfin
il a d'abord une réponse comme combien
faut-il inscrire deux points pour
remporter une partie de pétanque 15 13
sites et les deux équipes de rugby qui
participent au tournoi des six nations
et les équipes du ruc deux cités deux
équipes de rue de l'angleterre et la
france
bonne réponse comment s'appelle le biais
des deux français le plus titré aux jeux
olympiques d'hiver c'est fourcade
oui bonne réponse de quel club de basket
tony parker étiez président basse et
finir par armand mais voilà
[Applaudissements]
l'avenir c'est très difficile m
j'ai pris des acquis en deuxième
position non non non c'est pas ça
quel émoi alors galanterie convoyage
coiffure et un thème people n'a pas
jamais ça va ça mais ça prend c'est pas
possible
l'écurie allez on y va vous êtes prête
toujours top c'est parti quelle est la
nationalité de céline dion 3b coise
canadienne qu'elle était le métier de
meghan markle avant d'épouser le prince
a great bonne réponse quel est le vrai
nom de vincent cassel martin par mahmoud
vincent crochon qu'elle chroniqueuse de
la grande marque asseoir un calendrier
tous les ans lara logan bonne réponse
épeler le nom ami de johnny hallyday l
idée a irrigué beauvais tu réponds ses
achats elle est en jeu direct et à y
comment s'appelle le candidat de la
ferme de célébrités qui a inventé la
bogossitude jean pascal
non michael vendetta qui donne la
réplique à omar sy dans intouchables
s'installer en france soit 2 est de
quelle chanteuse le rappeur romeo et
disait-il le frère bonne réponse de quel
groupe faisait partie gims avant sa
carrière sur le web d'actionnaires
bonnes réponses en quelle année décédé
karl lagerfeld 2020 2010 9,2 à qui font
scandale et il rend visite en scooter
dames 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
réponse bon ça ne s'appelle julie donc
jean-michel voyage parce qu'il a décidé
de bientôt voyager les gens me vous êtes
prêts c'est parti sur quel continent se
situe l'himalaya chami c'est qu'on le
continent l'asie bonne réponse quel est
le plus long fleuve de france
bonne réponse quelle est la langue
officielle du costa rica la rényon bonne
réponse laquelle de ces deux villes est
la plus éloignée de paris brest ou
bordeaux bordeaux brest
quel est le pays le plus peuplé au monde
machine bonne réponse quelle est la
capitale de l'australie
une réponse qui est l'interprète de la
chanson sur voyage voyage quel pays à la
superficie la plus grande au monde
les mauvaises réponses l'assiette fait
partie de l'union européenne vrai ou
faux j'ai pas entendu faudrait est le
plus petit état du monde
en réponse la belgique est elle une
république où ils menaceront la belgique
est elle une république où nos bonnes
réponses comment s'appelle l'océan situé
entre l'afrique et l'australie
bonne réponse il y à 53 états aux états
unis vrai ou faux faux faux il y en a 50
si je suis née à lima dans quel pays
suit
[Musique]
la lutte est serrée
égalité les deux finalistes restant pour
l'instant donc focale l'installation
cinéma cinémas benjamin cinéma cinéma
cinéma cinémas et ferme ta gueule en
chroniqueur allez on y va comme c'est
parti qui a réalisé bienvenue chez les
ch'tis parole dany boon bonne réponse
quel acteur est le héros de la série du
gendarme à saint tropez la capitale dit
de funès bonne réponse quel film a fait
le plus gros poste sophis de tous les
temps pourquoi en france de tous les
torts à titanic non avengers endgame qui
a dépassé avatar quel jour de la semaine
les films sortis traditionnellement
synonyme trans bonnes réponses
à quel célèbre réalisateur français
doit-on le cinquième élément les ont
élus qui la bonne réponse combien y at
il eu de film de jurassic park 4 5 qui a
composé les musiques d' indiana jones
harry potter et vouloir le bien besoin
de réponses si je vais au cinéma voir un
film en 3d que doit supporter pourquoi
diable bonne réponse quel film a gagné
la palme d'or l'année dernière à cannes
barroso bonne réponse quelle saga avec
l'huile diesel tourne autour des
voitures et du tout dans quelle ville se
déroule la cérémonie des césars paris
dans une réponse quel est le titre du
troisième épisode de bronze et les
bronzés amis dans la vie bonne réponse
quel est le nom des frères ayant inventé
le cinéma une réponse compléter ce titre
de film maman j'ai raté l'avion
là
seule réponse qu'on benjamin castaldi
alors donc les inégalités il ya une
égalité vocale en moi je ne connais pas
le règlement alors en cas d'égalité je
vous pose une question chiffré est celui
qui est le plus proche de la vérité 1 et
de la bonne réponse passe en finale
d'accord alors c'est cyril et jean
michel vous jouez on va jouer maintenant
maintenant est ce quelque chose c'est la
rolls oui vous allez à poser oui mais
vous êtes imposé dans un instant car il
est 19 heures 36 je pleurais parce qu'on
avait à se retrouver dans un instant
leur lit ah oui merci
la caméra est ici et il y aura la finale
je vous rappelle que le grand gagnant
repartira avec ce magnifique trophée et
un trophée qui pourra se mettre où il
veut par n'importe quel côté a tout de
suite on est en direct et carole
rousseau vous fait le plaisir de nous
faire un grand concours des chroniqueurs
ce soir d'ailleurs je le dis aux
chroniqueurs g double cash et
chroniqueur et animateur
merci carole également vous avez invité
animatrice anna et beauté divine voilà
carole si on vous retrouve ce soir dans
catch haute tension également
oui oui c'est une soirée carole rousseau
carole rousseau est toujours vivante
mais carole rousseau aujourd'hui sur ses
billets ça préserve
oui c'est marrant vous ce prêt ray
carroll je te joins toi je tu t'es comme
ça et je la vois d'ici c'est une bombe
atomique ce n'est qu'un simon et moi
j'ai lu phare maquillage
ah oui on s'est croisé l'histoire
diverses mais savez-vous vieillit c'est
très très bien grand mais c'est vrai
elle ne vieillit pas vous deviez pas l
avantage les chéris mais dans le grand
concours des chroniqueurs pour l'instant
il ya eu quatre qualifiés
benjamin castaldi jean michel maire
clivé de béni et moi-même kelly est
éliminé c'est sûr puisqu'elle a fait que
7 points
il ya une égalité entre jean michel
dumont voilà avant cela je vais donc
vous poser une question très très
précises
il faudra répondre vraiment
précisément précisément mais avant cela
je voulais qu'on revienne sur une toute
petite vidéo si vous en êtes d'accord
un tout petit extrait de ce que nous
avons vécu il ya quelques minutes
hu sur ces 800 regard des liens qu'elle
est le plus long fleuve de france
bonne réponse quelle est la langue
officielle du costaricain bagnols bonne
réponse laquelle de ces deux villes est
la plus éloignée de paris brest ou
bordeaux bordeaux brest
quel est le pays le plus peuplé au monde
la chine bonne réponse quelle est la
capitale de l'australie bonnes réponses
qu'elle interprète de la série vous avez
soufflé j'ai soufflé des conneries si
vous à jean-michel oui mais elle a
soufflé des vraies réponses
alors je le dis il ya des règles
strictes dans cette émission on a le
droit de souffler des conneries mais des
vraies choses non mais je le dis j'en
viens juste pour ça vous n'êtes pas
disqualifier un lait jean michel tu le
savais donc il le savait la grande houle
elle a pas soufflé elle a accompagné sa
vie normale c'est une news agit mais
c'est très important maintenant monsieur
nouna monsieur jean michel maire soyez
prêts à répondre à cette question
quel âge à jean claude van damme à moi
je moi je les ai marre de cette chose 62
noms 59 bonne réponse était la muse est
mal tombé j'ai la passion des âges
nous sommes à chaque fois qu'une
célébrité je me demande quel âge alors
je vous offrirai les lie les téléphones
c'est à dire à chaque fois je me disais
qu'à la chaîne numéro de téléphone mais
comme on l'a reçu en piste à patricia la
pub non je suis encore d'une naïveté
absolue moi je suis et j'avais la fiche
ou est non alors sur les âges je vous
jure que j'adore ça michel blanc michel
blanc et je les regarde les reçus en
plus mini itx est blond 66 non elle sait
pas mais je vérifie que je rejoigne et
benjamin castaldi en finale bravo cyril
hanouna dominante
nous allons si vous en êtes d'accord
attaqué cette finale ça va vous êtes en
forme pas trop difficile pas trop
douloureux
j'ai peur tu as peur tu vas alors on y
va
vous n'êtes plus que deux vous allez
voir apparaître sur votre écran 12
questions médias répartis en quatre
thèmes célèbres gm animateurs et
animatrices jeter les thèmes mystère
télé réalité dans chacun de ces thèmes
trois questions une verte facile qui
vous fait marquer un point une orange
moyenne qui vous fait marcher marqué
deux points et une rouge questions
difficiles qui vous fera marqué trois
points vous allez répondre à chacune des
questions à tour à tour à la fin des
douze celui qui a le plus de points
remporte cette finale et se sublime
trophée qu'elle mettra où il veut dans
le sens qu'il veut nous disait cyril
tout à l'heure aux études
celui qui a fait le meilleur score
pendant la deuxième manche je peux
choisir en premier atelier et là il
s'agit de benjamin
ah je vois bien je vais prendre donc je
peux commencer par en bas on est
d'accord ou lettres télé répond ah bah
bien sûr télé réalité6 trois points il y
va fort un mariage pour lui au niveau
benjamin vous êtes prêts la question est
elle vous permet de marquer trois points
d'emblée qu'elle est la première télé
réalité à laquelle nabila a participé
mais l'amour est aveugle
c'est une bonne réponse cyril l'amour
est aveugle il aurait pu participer use
à vous de choisir un domaine cyril et 1°
inc et animateur animatrice
animateur/animatrice vert jaune va gros
le 3.3.1 allez on y va
vous êtes prêts oui quelle animatrice a
écrit le livre il est temps de choisir
sa vie les fils de à vous la met reçu
plusieurs formes bâtard attentes autant
il est temps de choisir sa vie il est
temps de choisir sa vie sophie davant
bonne réponse de jérémy nolin
[Applaudissements]
ces passagers pas d'oreillette savez
pourquoi j'ai dit ça parce que je me
suis ici ou karine le marchand mais je
me suis dit c'est quelqu'un peut-être
d'un que voilà je maintiens je vois bien
fait d'avoir beaucoup ça m'a dit quelque
chose qu'elle est venue a pas longtemps
quand aux large caps avec ça et taryn ça
fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas eue ouais
enfin selon le rapport l'actuelle loi
les bains jeter les trois points
jetez les trois points la question est
quel était le nom du jeu fort boyard
lors de sa première diffusion en 1990
c'est bien dans la merde
ah oui fort boyard ah ouais je peux bien
c'était je crois que ce n'est pas
partout et non la première à la première
vision box et épices partout où je vais
vous la première diffusion 90 ont été
les clés de boya les clés de fort boyard
est bon
je suis bonne humeur trichet l'a
défendue pas d'oreillette sayah public
derrière ils attaché non non j'ai pas
fait tout ça non il faut n'est allé
cyril à vous non mais c'est fort ce
qu'il a fait benji là bas il fallait le
trouver ça maintenant mais il est très
fort aurait pu trouver les clés de sa
maison mais au canada belgique thème
mystère bah oui 13.68 m mystère j'adore
la glace je ne vois pas pourquoi quand
même la question est dans la dernière
saison de masques singer en quoi était
déguisé sheila sheila et non répond pas
tout de suite comme ça donnerait la
bonne réponse vous laisse un peu de
temps pour réfléchir à l'est elle était
en elle était en celle à et gsm hspa
j'ai très peu regardé l'émission elle
n'était pas en aigle nom et ton coach
mauvaise réponse
elle était en écureuil chaîne devra vous
accorder ces trois à l'horizon il faut
changer et en fait ça rentrait pas dans
les cévennes avec mon nom et ma stingers
c'est ça le thème mystère c'est matt
singer à les benjamins vous menez on va
faire animateurs et la prise de points
deux points je me retrouvais que le
thème mystère entre la commission et
vous êtes prêts dans quelle ville et
mais nikos aliagas donc lui nikos
aliagas
à l'écouter au pardon s'il bat julien
qu'il était à la tête et bien non il est
né à paris non à quoi alors on apprend
des choses en plus ce sens c'est
formidable à paris nikos oui oui la
vienne jean ready athènes aux six mois
mais bon faut nicotine et la paris paris
cyril à vous de choisir un domaine je te
lis je t'ai lesquels le coup leur bal
vert orange rouge blanche et rouge on
l'a déjà fait par dont la question et
vous permet de marquer deux points
comment est surnommée la personne qui
remporte la finale des 12 coups de midi
le connard c'est m d'éminents ses
lectures nul et on est allé le dire ce
qu'est ce tu n'hésites de maître de midi
mais non maintenant question nul effet
on allait en parler sans fois ici c'est
tellement facile et à les accorder que
je suis pas là je suis pas là souvent
allez on y va mais la réception de
suivante comment nous ça ben gibbard
télé réalité 2 points bah ça c'est sa
spécialité à bennwihr
sa vie est une télé règne à la la la
question m
deux points face à new york l année
l'émission loft story et l arrivée sur
m6 en 2001 il s'est trompé
c'est normal de courant continu cyril
abou hatem mystères votre préféré la mrs
encore ma stingers ils sont cachés dans
tuer la gestion facile ou question
moyennes moyennes moyennes mais la
chance aux élèves en moyenne moitié la
question et 2.6 vous y répondez
correctement
quelle chaîne se trouve sur le canal 19
de la tnt
ah non tu arrêtes de 19,8 non 19 de la
tnt je crois que ceci est belle celle
enfin de leur pasteur et droite et doit
tétouan m'embêterait prend une réponse
de kanye west et oui alors qu'il
refusait pour cyril je suis inquiète pas
de moi sur scène c'est une question
facile zaiko mayala facilement face à
mes frères parce que toi tu es chômeuse
[Rires]
16 heures
cfl à prendre le nom des chaînes parker
dégoûté parce que je le savais pas vous
c'est tout pas être mauvais perdant
on occupe site était si fort pourquoi
t'es pas en finale série non non c'est
pas vrai non il ya encore hier pour
distribuer le donnerai jamais à travers
pire fois oui paris vatry jeter les
thèmes mystère c'est la liberté des
réalités et alors là une question celui
le fa si la question est qui a remporté
la première édition de la star academy
en faire bonne réponse de benjamin gates
il marque plus totalise 9 points à
laisser briller mais un point sur les
dernières questions pour qui un suspect
la loi ah oui et on se bat jusqu'au bout
cirer des produits question choisissez
un domaine a ajouté li jeter les honteux
muster a je crois le thème mystère est
un mystère
j'aime bien aller sympathique la
question est quel est le slogan de la
chaîne sémites à nos débats sur la tête
de mariage de seine ya un slogan sur
s'est vite réparé mais bon ça ça je le
sais c'est quoi le slogan barnaby
toujours plus aux animaux et hanouna à
ckoi et pas mal c'est quoi vous n'avez
pas la réponse va devoir se battre et ça
8 vivons ensemble
non j'en sais pas quoi on en a oublié là
le slogan c'est la nouvelle grande chine
en corse et 8 la nouvelle grande chef et
chantant qu'on attends tu n as bah
écoutez ça continue et bah écoute et m6
et la petite chaîne qui monte à l'est
bah je crois que c'est qu'un stasi qui a
fini par question pour les deux
dernières
et moi c'est un jeu tunisiens aziz badji
s'est pas jeté les allées quitte ou
double à on y va et ben voilà donc quel
jeu télé doit-on dire du haut carré ou
cash avant de répondre si vous garez au
cash et je n'ai guide midi bien sûr non
5 points à toi pour ton cul la gueule 5
secondes
[ __ ] benjamin wittes de limites nagui
la guinée mior trop tard la bonne
réponse cheryl dommage mais a glissé pas
positif alors j'avais un trou de mémoire
va pourtant pas les missions de manière
si vous répondez oui alors non
correctement à la prochaine question
syrie ne peut pas gagner
j'ai d'aussi énorme arnaque je donnerai
mon pour trophée bonne chose elle hésite
quand même
alors si on n'y va pas aller au camp se
parait pas les le panache rénovateurs à
les battre ici
il reste animateur/animatrice absolument
la question facile bien sûr voulait
marquer cinq points de services ti le
monde veut prendre sa place je ne l'aimé
pas en bouche que je te dise de l'ipod
avait pas et que vous l'avez très
célèbre des fonds en bouche les paons
bush l'un des leviers de la pression tu
craques des connards de qu'il a la
pression on craque médecin c'est une
bière ce mec oui la question est qui
anime actuellement ça commence
aujourd'hui sur france 2 on me respecte
pas
[Rires]
tu vas prendre ce trop firent parole tu
sais quoi moi c'est que ces castaldi
quelques nippon je le dis
[Applaudissements]
mais les victoires
merci et voilà et du pôle a été comme ça
tu vois tu peux le mettre dans un sac à
main tu vas voilà tu le mets comme as
voilà oui tu peux prendre également
cammas est si bien sûr la voie là aussi
pour tracter des choses c'est qu'il est
très beau tu veux garder je suis jamais
démentis se le dire d'accord bien sûr à
ne pas mettre dans toutes les fêtes
merci